stuttgart ein mob von 5 100 randalierern
plündert geschäfte verletzt 19
polizisten
es gibt 24 festnahmen politik und
experten sind sich einig solche szenen
hat es noch nie gegeben
die polizei spricht von frust in der
event- und partyszene
viele sehen das anders nicht nur wir
hier in stuttgart müssen uns damit
beschäftigen wie es passieren kann dass
jugendliche insbesondere auch mit
migrationshintergrund zum teil uns
entgleiten womit haben wir es zu tun
drohen solche gewaltausbrüche auch
anderswo warum hat man nicht die frage
gestellt wie der alkoholkonsum war ob
die drogen konsumiert haben ob es
vorstrafen gehabt das wäre ja alles auch
fragen gewesen die wichtig sind und ich
finde dass man daran eben schon auch
merkt dass diese bilder die er eine
gewalteskalation ausgelöst haben von
null auf hundert die erschrecken die
menschen natürlich auch und dass das
ausgerechnet im beschaulichen ja reichen
stuttgart passiert was ja auch bekannt
ist eigentlich dafür dass es sehr
bürgerlich ist da keine probleme gibt
ich glaube das ist kein zufall also das
passiert natürlich auch vor dem
hintergrund
ich sag mal stuttgart 21 haben wir jetzt
schon vergessen da gab es ja mal was ja
dann ist es auch dort passiert und
trotzdem ist es natürlich auch so dass
wir eine menge jugendlicher haben ob mit
oder ohne zuwanderungsgeschichte die
desillusioniert sind und das heißt nicht
dass ich damit entschuldigen will oder
das rechtfertigen will sondern jeder
diejenigen die dort eine straftat
begangen haben die dort scheiben
eingeschlagen haben die dort geplündert
haben hat die ganze härte des
rechtsstaates verdient ganz klarer maßen
aber es ist nicht so dass es ein kampf
ist sozusagen zwischen den kulturen
sondern das gehört zur wahrheit dazu
auch wenn im moment ist lieben in
schwarz-weiß debatten uns aus zulassen
dass auf der seite der polizei die
menschen sind mit zuwanderungsgeschichte
und die aufrufe und deutschen und auf
der anderen seite genauso bzw
die hälfte der deutschen die dabei war
war die dann auch nicht integriert es
ist eine soziale frage und trotzdem sage
ich wir müssen über probleme reden wenn
der migration zu der guten rolle spielt
und da ist natürlich der aspekt der
allah akbar rufe die ja sozusagen dann
auch wir eingegangen sind die zu
überschriften geworden sind er ist
sozusagen nicht trivial und das etwas
damit zu tun dass unter diesem
schlachtruf beispielsweise der es damals
gemordet hat
das weiß ich zum beispiel aufgrund der
tatsache dass ich selber sie denn bin in
stuttgart leben auch jesidischen frauen
das leben christi leben auch muslime die
vor diesem terrorbanden geflohen sind
das heißt die angst die sowas auslöst
die betrifft alle gleichermaßen wichtig
dass wir die wirklich differenzierte
kuchen auf wenn es ums schwefel